With Maze Runner: The Scorch Trials out now,
let's take a look at 7 things you probably
didn't know about the big-screen adaptation
of James Dashner's best-selling novel.
According to the cast, The Scorch Trials was
even more physically demanding and involved
even more running than the first movie.
So, when Ki Hong Lee, who plays Minho, was
running up sand dunes, he suffered a minor
fracture to one of his knees.
But that wasn't the only injury he sustained
on set.
He also cut himself several times after he
asked for a real knife instead of using a
blunt one for a scene where he flipped a knife
and caught it.
As for Kaya Scodelario, who plays Teresa,
although she avoided injury while filming
The Maze Runner, she wasn't so lucky on The
Scorch Trials where she had back and knee
problems from all the running.
And being barefoot for part of the movie proved
its own hazard as Scodelario ran into a bolt
sticking that was up out of the set floor
and pulled off her toenail!
The main cast took part in a boot camp before
The Scorch Trials began filming.
However, whereas training for the first movie
included learning survival skills and camping
overnight in the wooded Louisiana location
used for the Glade, The Scorch Trials boot
camp involved running 2 to 3 miles a day in
Albuquerque's mile-high altitude and practising
stunts such as a long slide through a closing
door and a leap-into-mid-air-kick.
Most of the movie's sand dune scenes were
filmed at Pajarito Dunes, west of Albuquerque
in New Mexico.
The design team removed footprints and vehicle
tracks from the dunes by sweeping with rakes
and used a low-hovering helicopter as a giant
fan to create a swirling effect in the sand.
After a hard day filming The Scorch Trials,
many of the cast spent the evenings hanging
out together, playing Mario Kart and cooking.
Kaya Scodelario made Brazilian dishes and
reckoned she was the best in the kitchen because
she's inherited her Brazilian mother's cooking
gene.
Dylan O'Brien's specialities were chicken
parmesan and breaded chicken cutlets, while
Dexter Darden, who plays Frypan, loved to
grill and also made a mean macaroni and cheese
as well as fried chicken.
The movie's party sequence was shot over two
days at an 8,500-square-foot mansion known
as The Castle in downtown Albuquerque.
The Castle was built over two years from 2006
and was the home of late jewellery designer
Gertrude Zachary.
During filming, the walls of the mansion were
covered in dark green wallpaper aged with
mildew and staining to give this quite new
building the feel of a grand mansion past
its glory days.
The design team also added hundreds of candles
melted down into mounds, and VHS tape that
was pulled out to use as streamers.
The dark tunnels, storm drains and diversion
channels under the University of New Mexico
Hospital in Albuquerque proved the perfect
place to film scenes set beneath the desolate
landscape of the Scorch.
The sequences in Jorge's lair were filmed
on sets constructed at Albuquerque Studios
and at the vacant railyard complex south of
downtown Albuquerque, where movies including
The Avengers and Terminator: Salvation, and
TV show Breaking Bad have also filmed.
The design of where the scavengers live in
the lair was inspired by the look of Kowloon
Walled City in Hong Kong, a now-demolished
stacked building structure where people lived
in very cramped conditions.
Lots of the objects used to dress the set
of Jorge's penthouse were bits of metal and
junk furniture found in salvage and recycling
yards.
Now, let me know in the comments below, who's
your favourite character in The Maze Runner
series?
And what's your favourite book-to-big-screen
adaptation & why?
If you enjoyed this video, do please share
it, hit the thumbs-up button and subscribe
for more things you didn't know, as well as
movie reviews and interviews.
Thanks for watching!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!